Hey, John here.
A very warm welcome to the CAM model, otherwise known as ESIP.
Now, this is a model that we use here in Eden Rise, which at first glance,
or looking at it to start with, looks very simple, and it is simple,
but it's also extremely powerful in terms of helping you and us as a team
to do our jobs better, work together as a team, grow as people, as individuals,
and also professionally.
It's a super powerful tool that brings so much clarity that you're going to find
that as you learn this tool and you go through this tool, you're going to have more wisdom,
you're going to have more insights into things that are happening when you're working
and collaborating with people, when you're doing your job, how you can do things better.
Now, I don't even really like the word job, but perhaps you can call it your purpose here at Eden Rise.
It's a much nicer, more powerful word, and we're going to explore this together as we go through this model.
Now, the lady you're seeing on the screen, her name is Sharon Pearson,
so she's been a mentor of mine for many years.
I've worked with her in person quite a lot, and she's developed one of the most successful coaching schools
in the world where they have helped thousands and thousands of coaches,
and this model I'm about to show you has helped all kinds of organizations succeed,
whether it's churches, whether it's charitable organizations, whether it's high functioning companies,
multi-million dollar companies, all kinds of businesses, all kinds of organizations
have benefited tremendously from this model.
In fact, there's even been work done in countries like Burma, Myanmar,
where we're helping government learn to restructure through this model.
It is a very, very powerful system that I'm going to show you right now.
So I'm excited to show you this, and this is going to help you if you're someone that loves to grow
and you're someone that wants to really thrive here in Eden Rise.
So let's explore it together.
I'm just going to scroll through to this section here.
Now, what I'm going to invite you to do is just press pause so that you can read over this yourself,
and once you've read it all, we can continue and I'll unpack it more for you.
So just go ahead and press pause now.
Okay, so welcome back.
So let's begin with the environment.
Everything starts with the environment.
So what is the environment?
Well, here it's got the culture of the organization.
And so what's in the culture is how does a place feel?
What's the vibe?
What's the feeling that you get when you walk into a coffee shop,
when you walk into a business, when you walk into someone's home,
you're entering into an atmosphere, a culture.
And that culture has many things inside it that make up that culture.
Things like what is the vision and the purpose they're working towards.
If you walk into a company culture where it's all about making money and winning,
it's very aggressive kind of competitive culture.
It's not very necessarily a healthy culture, I would say.
Otherwise you walk into another culture, another environment where the purpose is
to bring connection, to inspire others, to make a difference in this world.
The frequency, the energy there is very, very different.
So this is the environment that we hold as individuals and together as a company
or as any organization.
Now, within that, there's also the goals of the company.
So I gave an example, it's all about making money or it's all about creating
an amazing customer experience.
So that's the main goal.
And that goal shifts your attitude.
So also in here that's not on the screen, things like your attitudes that you bring,
the beliefs that you have.
Here it's also got emotional aptitudes.
So what does that mean?
That's like your emotional awareness.
Are you someone that can sense if someone's a bit down?
Are you very cold emotionally or you're disconnected?
So there's another way of looking at this is emotional intelligence.
So what is the emotional intelligence of the team?
So these are all parts of environment.
Now there's a lot more to it than this, but for the sake of this introductory video,
that is what the environment is.
Now the environment, you can also think of it like the collective consciousness also
determines what systems do we need to have in place.
So structure, system structure in order for us to achieve our vision and purpose.
So if our purpose is to rescue a thousand children and help them,
or is it to create incredible people, experiences here at In The Rise, whatever it may be,
that's our vision, that's our purpose, that's our mission.
Now obviously we unpack mission and vision in more details,
but let's just say to keep it simple, that's our vision, our mission we want to do.
Well the structure is like well how are we going to do it?
What are the pieces? What are the structural elements?
So just like a car, you have a vision to drive your car to a destination,
that's a vision, a purpose, but the car has around 30,000 structural pieces.
Well that's what gets you there.
So the structure is super, super important.
Now a lot of times people who are immature, they haven't developed yet,
they have these beautiful visions, but they're very lazy and sloppy when it comes to structures,
and they don't end up achieving what they want to achieve.
Because I just give the example, for example, with the car, you need all those structural pieces
in order to get to that destination quite straightforward.
So within the component of structure, we have things like KPI's.
What's a KPI? A key performance indicator.
So it's a measurement basically of what we're measuring.
We're looking at things like how do we measure it? Why do we measure it?
When do we measure it? What are the steps in order to achieve something?
What are the checklists, the blueprints, the structures, the policies,
the manuals on how to drive the tractor, maybe a little video demonstration.
These are all the structural pieces that help things run more efficiently.
So that's the structure.
About 80% of business development coaching happens inside the first two components.
If you've got a really good culture, really good vision, beliefs, great atmosphere,
and you've got really amazing structures and systems with the team who are using them
and implementing them and refining them, you are like 80% of success.
It's like that's where the most of the success happens in those first two components that we're exploring here.
So let's move on to number three, implementation.
So here we're going what systems are actually used?
Now we can put systems in place within the company or in the organization,
and people are like, well, you know, I don't have to use those systems.
I'm special. I'm unique. It doesn't feel good for me to use those systems.
I don't want to do it. That's a cultural problem if we come back to environment,
because the question here is going, well, what is actually being used?
Well, we're not using them or we're using them sometimes and sometimes we're not.
Well, how are they being used? How are we accessing these systems?
So that's the implementation component. We've got things like how are these systems taught
and how is the success and education assessed?
So how are the leadership, how are we helping others access these systems?
How are we supporting them to use them? By which way do they use them?
And then we've got people. Now people, we're all people.
So there is no company. There is no team without us. So we're all part of that.
But in terms of this ESIP model, this CAM model, the question here we're looking at
is what training has the person received in the structure and in the systems?
Now normally if you're somewhat advanced and you have a lot of success
and you'll bring in what you'd be expected to bring in intelligent systems to a company,
but if you're someone very junior, very more elementary at the beginning level,
then you need to come into an organization that has systems to support you,
that you can get going. So high level professionals who have typically larger salaries,
they bring in incredible amount of sophistication systems and expertise
that helps the organization jump up to a high level.
For those who are more elementary, they are learning systems,
improving systems, developing systems as they grow.
So the question here is what's the support? Right now you're getting this system.
This is a system I'm teaching, a system of thinking, a system of approaching problems,
a system of diagnosing problems. I'll explain that more in a moment.
This is all what's happening in the people section and the question here is,
is the team getting the support they need to grow?
Now Eden Rise is what we call a high growth culture coming back to environment here.
Here we love to grow. We believe that we're lifelong learners,
that you're green and growing, life is about growth.
It's in fact one of the core human needs in human needs psychology,
is the need to grow and to feel progress, to feel development.
So however, by contrast, some people don't like to grow.
They like to be just comfortable, lazy and just do enough just to get by.
That's not us here in Eden Rise. We love to grow. It's more fun.
It's more interesting. It's more exciting.
So the way to grow is to make sure you're getting mentorship,
you're getting access to trainings and systems just like this,
and you're willing on a personal level to receive feedback.
This is probably one of the most important components.
Your willingness to see feedback as I dare say love or growth
or the thing that helps me move forward to my destination.
Why do I say that? Having worked myself with professional leaders and athletes for years,
this is the number one thing I'm gauging.
What is that person's receptivity to feedback?
Do they love it? Do they like it? Do they contract in their physiology?
Do they expand? Do they get excited? Do they use it? Do they implement it?
Do they come back and share how that feedback helped them?
This is what allows them to grow, to develop.
So that's really, really important that you're getting that feedback
and you're looking for that feedback.
So that's the people component.
So that's the overview of ESIP.
Now what you'll find is whenever problems are happening as a leader
and you're watching this because you're invited to be a leader and to grow,
you're going to be out of diagnosis through these four silos.
Is it the problem with someone's beliefs, their attitude?
Is it that they lack vision? Is it that they're emotionally disconnected?
Is it the fact that, no, they have great attitude and vision
and they're ready to roll, but they lack the structure.
They haven't got enough systems and structures to support them
or maybe they're not getting the systems and the training and the mentorship
that's happening at the peak component.
Or maybe they're someone that likes to be abstracting the philosophical
but they don't like to get on with it and do the work.
They like to talk a lot and reason and they like to hang out in that space.
So they're not really people of implementation and getting it done.
Now that's when you can diagnose yourself.
You can also assess those who you're leading,
but it also gives you a fantastic window to diagnose where things go wrong,
where things have not been planned out, where things have not been communicated.
And obviously we can impact this a lot more,
but it's a super useful tool to look into any organization
you're going to be part of in your life, whether it's here at In-N-Rise
or whether it's in a social club or whatever group community you're going to be involved in.
This wisdom, this training is going to help you tremendously,
almost like have X-ray vision glasses to look deeper into situations
so that you can ultimately benefit and thrive and make a difference to those
that you're wanting to contribute to.
So let's scroll down this document a little bit
and take a look at what else is kind of in here.
Now I just want to press pause once again
and just let you absorb this for a moment.
But I also want you to not concern about remembering all this.
This is just to give you an appetizer.
This is just to introduce you to this model
and to allow you to start to think through this process
because you're not expected to know all this and do it all straight away.
It's just to help you make an introduction to this process that we use here at In-N-Rise.
So I'm going to press pause now and just give you a moment to absorb all that's on the screen here.
Okay, welcome back.
Now again, the purpose of that was just to read over it and digest a little bit.
And now I'm just going to scroll a little bit further down
just to show you the components instruction.
Now at In-N-Rise, we highly value systems instruction.
It's super, super important, not because we like systems for the sake of it,
because they free us up to be more present, to connect and have meaningful experiences.
That's the purpose of systems.
So, and I'm interchanging the word structuring systems because they can be used either one.
Now, when we look at it here, here are some of the categories, the many categories of what's inside structures.
Now, as you go through this, begin to imagine how this applies to your role,
what you do here at In-N-Rise or what you're going to do if you're new here,
working with us or coming to join the team.
So this is some, a bunch of different things here, divisions in the company,
the equipment, the systems, your operations manual, the checklist and templates,
the procedure, how to do something.
And this can be applied from anything from the procedure to cleaning a pool,
to maintaining a tractor, to anything at all that happens within In-N-Rise.
We've got different components here.
So this is again, just to wet your appetite.
As we scroll through, of course, you can pause this and read more.
And I think we're going to just stop this here as I can just scroll.
And this is the document. It's more of an introduction document.
Now, again, the purpose of this video as I scroll back up is just to introduce you to this model
so that you can be familiar and have a little bit of an orientation to the main model that we use.
Again, the benefits of this unified communication, it helps you diagnose different situations,
it helps you realize where your strengths are.
There's so many layers in this. If you love to learn, this stuff's so exciting.
You have even archetypes, if you know you are those, how they overlay.
So the visionary is more the environment, the architect is more in the details.
The dynamo is that you get it all done.
And the people is more the collaborator who works to get things,
people talking and sharing information really well.
So we all have strengths and weaknesses in all these.
So the CAM model helps us better understand ourselves, better understand our team.
And ultimately, why this all matters is that we can thrive, we can grow,
and we can make a difference doing what we love.
So I hope you've enjoyed this introduction to the critical alignment model, the CAM,
that's the acronym CAM, otherwise known as ESIP.
Thank you so much.